on entendrait que de ma cuisine on
tenterait de faire sortir le vote
merci à tout le monde ça a été une super
belle campagne constructive
puis elle est encouragée moi en me
donnant votre premier choix
la campagne ça a été pour moi un
extraordinaire aventure humaine les gens
que j'ai rencontrés les histoires qui
m'ont raconté ça vaut mieux préparés à
les représenter
toute une course intense du début
jusqu'à la fin
l'été on ne pas trop vous passer mais ça
valait le coup le parti québécois va
renouer avec les victoires et ce grâce à
l'indépendance
vraiment fier de la campagne que je suis
amené jah l'ennemi avec mes convictions
avec mon coeur avec mes tripes
j'ai parlé vrai jamais fait de compromis
des raccourcis